what's your superpower a friend of mine
Janie one of her skills is helping
people identify what their superpower is
it's so important because if you are
working on the wrong thing if you're
trying to get good at something you're
not good at it's gonna be a constant
struggle constant uphill fight if you
think about baseball players some
baseball players are great homerun
hitters some people are great at
stealing bases some baseball players are
great at playing defense you got to
figure out which one you're really good
at because if you're really good at home
runs then you're not going to be
successful you're not going to be happy
trying to become the best base dealer or
the best of defense you're gonna have
your most success but going out and
learning how to crush homeruns and be
the guy who hits home runs you have more
success doing that being great at that
than trying to be okay at everything you
don't have to be well-rounded know what
your superpower is and develop it and be
the best in the world at it and use it
everywhere that's what's gonna help
separate you and surround yourself with
the people you need who have superpowers
of their own and you become like the
x-men right you got your awesome team
everybody has the powers you come
together and you do something amazing so
don't worry about being great at
everything focus one thing your one
superpower be your home run hitter make
that amazing and go out and crash it
believe you'll see watching like a video
thumbs up below it makes me to do more
for you and let me know what you think
leave a comment give me your thoughts
you got a question leave it below I make
a video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon